sorry just taking a little nap here
after Microsoft's two and a half hour
Windows 10 keynote but don't worry I was
paying attention here are the five
things you need to know about Windows 10
in under two minutes first thing you
need to know Microsoft wants Windows
tend to run everywhere everywhere
Microsoft shut off Windows 10 on phones
tablets laptops a giant TV even a
holographic headset but it isn't the
same interface on all those devices the
layout will change and adapt to whatever
form factor you're using I was helping
Microsoft with charged $10 for Windows
10 but instead it's free that's right
completely free to upgrade if you're
upgrading from Windows 7 Windows 8.1
Windows Phone 8.1 you will get a free
upgrade for the first year it's unclear
what happens after that year ago hey
Cortana they're a pretty big deal now
that's right Microsoft's personal
assistant is coming to Windows 10 in a
big way the personal assistant will be
built right into the Start menu where
you can ask her questions and she'll
prompt you with more information you may
need she can also dictate emails Xbox is
also coming to your Windows 10 PC in a
way you'll actually care about - with
Windows 10 you can easily capture
portions of gameplay on video and share
them with your friends but even bigger
you can stream and play Xbox one games
right on your Windows laptop or tablet
I'm saving the best for last in the
future Microsoft wants us to wear these
this is totally Minority Report like
stuff yes Microsoft wants us to navigate
Windows with Holograms and a device it
will release this year called the
hololens with the headset you'll be able
to see holographic images and manipulate
them with just your hands you have to be
wearing the headset to see those images
but you'll be able to use it to design
things play Minecraft even video chat
whoa I just had a crazy dream that
Microsoft unveiled Windows with
Holograms